But we know the first part of the
answer because that sequence hasn't changed. We know
it's going to be QA for glutamene and alamine.
But then what's going to happen here? Instead of CTT,
we're going to get CCT. Where's CCU in the genetic
code? And CCU codes for P or Proline, PRO.
Well lets go to the next one, well now look what's happened, we've shifted and
this T here now goes into the next corner so we
get TGA, we come to the generic code and we find that
a TGA codes for nothing, its a stop code on, so
that means protein synthesis ends, no
more translation, done, stop, finito, right,
[FOREIGN].
All we get are these three amino acids right here.